اثر التعاون العسكريه الروسيه الايرانيه
قلق العديد من دول المنطقه خاصه بعد
التقارير التي تحدثت عن عزم موسكو تقديم
تكنولوجيا عسكريه متطوره للطيران من بين
هذه التكنولوجيا طائرات مقاتله حديثه
هذه هي التطورات تتزامن مع توقف الجهود
الدبلوماسيه لمعالجه الملف النووي
الايرانيه وكذلك ايضا عوده التلويح
الاسرائيلي وربما الامريكيه احيانا بوضع
الخيار العسكري ضد منشات طهران النوويه
على الطاوله لمناقشه هذا الموضوع وغيره من
الموضوعات معنا القائد السابق للقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه الفريق اول كانت كنزي
اولا اا جنرال المكانزي اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا في البدايه كيف تقيم التعاون
العسكري ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحول فيها في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وما الذي يحتاجه حلفاء الولايات
المتحده في هذه المنطقه وتحديدا في هذه
المرحله الصعبه للحفاظ على انفسهم من اي
تهديدات
معكم اليوم لقد تشرفت خلال عملي في
القياده المركزيه بالتفاعل مع العديد من
اصدقاءنا وشركائنا في المنطقه اعتقد ان كل
دوله من دول المنطقه تواجه خطرا محدقا من
ايران وهذا التهديد يتمثل في صواريخهم
البالستيه
ومسيراتهم الجويه وصواريخ كروز لمهاجمه
الاهداف البريه وبالتاكيد تهديد
الميليشيات المسلحه التابعه لهم عبر
المنطقه اعتقد ان كل ذلك كان له الاثر في
توحيد دول المنطقه بينما يحاولون ايجاد
السبل الفعاله لصياغه استجابه مشتركه في
وجه هذا التهديد الحقيقي والمتنامي
جنرال المكانزي مع عوده رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بينامين نتنياهو الى السلطه
عادت تلويح الاسرائيلي من جديد
بضروره توجيه ضربه عسكريه لمنشئه طهران
نوويه برايك الى اي مدى هذا السيناريو من
المتوقع ان يحدث وكذلك الى اي مدى هناك
قناعه في واشنطن بهذا الخيار الاسرائيلي
يتمثل في ضروره عدم امتلاك ايران سلاح
نوويه اعتقد ان الجميع يتفقون على ان
سلسبيل لتحقيق هذا الحل هو عبر جهود لا
تشمل الحرب وعبر الحلول الدبلوماسيه لكن
كل دوله لها الحق في كل وقت للدفاع عن
نفسها وهذا يشمل اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده لا اعتقد اننا يجب ان نزيح اي
خيار عن الطاوله خاصه في الوقت الحالي
بينما نواجه هذه المشكله
من يقيم مخاطر البرنامج الايراني للصواريخ
البالسيه بانه اكثر خطوره حتى من الملف
النووي الايراني هل تتفق مع وجهه النظر
هذه
انا من بين هؤلاء الاشخاص اعتقدوا ان سنام
القدرات البالستيه الايرانيه الى جانب
نوعين الاخرين من الاسلحه التي نقشناها
للتو وهي صواريخ الكروز والمنظومه المسيره
وفرت قدرته عاليه لايران عبر السنوات
الخمس الى السبع الماضيه
يمتلكون قدرات كبيره وبامكانهم استخدامهم
هذا التاجيرانهم هذه الليله وليس في مرحله
المستقبل
هو الحال مع الملف النووي بل يمتلكون
قدرات بامكانهم استخدامها فورا وهذا الامر
مقلق جدا واعرف انه جذب الانتباهه
المباشره لدول المنطقه
حديث الان بانه روسيا ربما ستقوم بتزويد
ايران بمقاتلات حديثه الى اي مدى هذا
الامر ان تم سيضاعف من قدرات ايران
القتاليه وكيف يتم التعامل مع هذا الامر
سواء من قبل الولايات المتحده او حتى من
قبل الحلفائها في المنطقه
ستزيد من التوترات في هذا الوضع الخطير
اعتقد ان هذا التصرف غير مسؤول من روسيا
في حال فعل ذلك ولكن كما شاهدنا فان روسيا
قدره على القيام بتصرفات غير مسؤوله
وبنطاق يحبس الانفاق فلا شيء تفعله روسيا
سوف يفاجئوني واعتقد اننا قادرون على
معالجه هذا التهديد اذا ما ترى
جنرال ماكنزي كيف تنظر اصلا للتحالف
العسكري القائم الان ما بين طهران وموسكو
هل تعتقد بانه تحالف قوي قادر على الصمود
ام انه تحالف الضروره كما يطلق عليه بعض
الخبراء
وربما تحالف ياس روسيا في مشكله بسبب
حربها العدائيه في اوكرانيا وحقيقه جلبهم
لاسلحه من ايران واطلاقها ضد اهداف في
اوكرانيا يدفعون جميعا لتامله في ضعف
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه وما يقلقني اكثر
من ذلك بصراحه هو تدفق التكنولوجيا الى
ايران من روسيا هذا الامر مقلق جدا سبق ان
تحدثنا قليلا عن احتمال تزويدهم بالطائرات
المقاتله وكذلك هناك احتمالنا لتزويدهم
بالمكونات المتقدمه التي بامكانها تعزيز
قدراتي صواريخهم البالستيه والقدرات
الاخرى المقلقه لنا جميعا هذا امر مقلق
جدا لنا جميعا الجنرال المكانزي في اكثر
من تصريح اثنيت على القدرات الدفاعيه لعدد
من دول المنطقه لكن برايك هل القدرات
الدفاعيه التي تمتلكها دول المنطقه همم
الان في هذه المرحله هي قدرات كافيه لردعه
اي تهديدات ام ان دول المنطقه بحاجه الى
مزيد من القدرات الدفاعيه
لقد حفظنا على مس سميته بوضعيه ردع
المتباينه منذ سنوات عديده وقد تمكن لها
من منع العديد من الهجمات من قبل دوله
ايران واوكلائها ومنعنا ايران من استخدام
المنظمات الارهابيه لتحقيق اهدافها اعتقد
ان هذه الوضعيه لا تزال قائمه ولكن دائما
هناك اشياء بوسع من القيام بها وعلى شكل
خاص في مجال الدفاع الجوي والصاروخي اذا
من دلعت حرب في المنطقه في ستكون حرب
صواريخ كروز وصواريخ البالستيه والمسيرات
الجويه وبالتالي فهذه امور علينا لاستمرار
بالع على تحسينها مع اصدقائنا وشركائنا في
المنطقه ليس فقط فيما يخص اسلحتهم
وقدراتهم بل كذلك في اسلوب مشاركه
المعلومات ومقربه مشكله بشكل جماعي جنرال
ماكنزي كنت تشغل القائد القياده المركزيه
اثناء الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
والان هناك مع عوده الجمهوريين للسيطره
على مجلس النواب بدء تحقيق فيما يتعلق
بالمشاهد الفوضويه للقوات الامريكيه التي
حدثت اثناء الانسحاب اذا سالت بشكل مباشر
ستقول من المسؤول عن هذه المشاهد
بلاي ستيشن قرار انسحابي من افغانستان كان
قرارا سياسيا اتخذته القياده الوطنيه
للولايات المتحده ولذلك فهي تتحمل مسؤوليه
ما حدث بعد اكثر من عام من الانسحاب
الامريكي جنرال ماكينز هل تعتقد بان ما
حدث كان خطوه صحيحه ام لا
مساله الانسحاب اوصيت بعدم مغادره
افغانستان بشكل كامل وقد تسنت لي الفرصه
لتعبير عن هذا الراي ولكن قرارا مغيرا
اتخذ وهذا هو اسلوب عمل نظامنا وانا
اختلفت براي معها واعتقد ان قرار المغادره
واخراج كل شيء بسرعه اسهم بشكل مباشر في
انهيار افغانستان والاوضاع التي حدثت في
اغسطس وكل ما حدث منذ ذلك الوقت في
افغانستان
لكن الان ومنذ عوده الطالبان الى السلطه
تنام ظهور هذا التنظيم من جديد هل تعتقد
برايك بانه تنظيم داعش من المفترض او ربما
يعود من جديد ليشكل نفس الخطوره التي
شكلها في السابق قبلها سواء في افغانستان
او حتى في سوريا او العراق
خرسان في افغانستان لا تزال لديهم الرغبه
في دعم هجمات خارجيه واقصد بذلك هجمات ضد
اراضي الولايات المتحده وربما ضد حلفائنا
وشركائنا الغربيين وكذلك شركاؤنا
واصدقائنا في المنطقه لا تزال لديهم هذه
الرغبه سواء كانت نابعه من افغانستان او
دول اخرى في المنطقه وما يمنعهم من القيام
بذلك هو ضغوط مكافحه الارهاب الفعاله من
قبل القوات المحليه بمساعدتنا عندما يكون
ذلك ضروريا ولا يوجد الكثير من ذلك في
افغانستان اليوم الفريق اول كانت ما كنزي
القائد السابق للقياده المركزيه الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا